ladies and gentlemen the mug shot has
arrived in fact the image we saw was
real it was real it was a photo of a
photo of the mug shot and CNN is
reporting this is the Fulton County
mugshot of Donald Trump this photo is
history in the making and I'm sure it
will be on a plethora of t-shirts yeah
and posters I would uh uh you know you
guys feel free to make this but um I
think we'll we'll make one we'll take
that image of trump we'll put it on a
poster so it looks like the Obama hope
poster but it'll say Revenge instead
yeah and I would like to put one of
those posters up and probably just how
can we give them out for free can we
like give posters of troubles just as
Revenge we could just do a mailing like
yeah you could do a PDF and people could
print it themselves in all sizes right
and then anyone can just take it that's
a good idea so I don't know do we have
anything from the crew listening they
can just make it and then we'll just
publish it and be like there you go
Revenge
the mug shot is here
you know and some people were saying the
uh fourth
the fourth surrender would be
meaningless and it would not matter nah
this is this is it this is the moment
the other ones were like slow build up
this right now with the mug shot well
this is unpardonable so this has the
teeth I mean New York is unbeardable
State charges but it wasn't election
related right this this is clearly
political for one simple reason the most
famous man in the world does not need a
mug shot
Trump can't walk down a street in Peru
and not like Trump can be in Utica
how do you pronounce it in Alaska and
they're going to be like Trump Trump
trump could be in the Aleutian Islands
an abandoned military base and if anyone
walks by for any reason maybe maybe yo
the only place Trump can go where they
need a mugshot North Sentinel Island
all right no you can't do you get there
you go
but that's the only place in the world
except for like uncontacted Amazon
tribes I guess but if Trump went to set
north central island they'd be like who
are you actually they wouldn't say
English they'd just be like
what is this like it's a it's a crazy
guy did you see his truth about that no
what did he say oh God it was hilarious
he was talking about he goes
I have to put up a bond because I'm a
Flight Risk and he said well gee I
wonder would I possibly leave be leaving
on my plane my ever unrecognizable plane
with a giant branding on he goes no
perhaps I should fly commercial because
no one would recognize me there go
Incognito yeah yes it was it was
hilarious it's dumb I mean this is
something true Trump proves over and
over again which is that he is the
entity
in and of himself he's recognizable and
people will flock wherever he is the
Tucker interview had what 100 million
views and less than eight hours yeah
it's at like 220. it's insane people
want to know what he's doing there's no
way that he would just not be noticed if
he tried to sneak out of the country and
also he's running for president so he
probably doesn't want to leave he
probably wants to be here on purpose I
think the mug shot is just for Democrats
to fundraise honest I don't think it'd
be a good idea for him to campaign to
people in in like somewhere in South
America I think he can do whatever he
wants to hear the America first
president you want to stay in America
he's going to take a secret service
detail with him on his flight it's just
so ludicrous why is there a bond yeah
and why is there a flight rate because
it intimidates people this isn't all
about government intimidation why is the
bot higher that's my current one like it
should be 200 million
if it was a legit Bond yup it would be
200 million or two billion dollars
because he really is a Flight Risk and
it's a problem but 200 000 that's pocket
change imagine a mob boss and died on
all these counts Rico they would not let
him go they're anyone else and that is
not even high crimes if it's like the
mob boss was engaged in a criminal
Enterprise where they were selling drugs
you know and they were organizing and
doing this and doing that we believe
that he's a major Flight Risk We're not
gonna let him out they'd be like yup and
the lawyer would argue be like how dare
you blah blah is innocent women guilty
and they'd be like we have a
preponderance of evidence Donald Trump's
accused of trying to overthrow the
government
you'd think for that they'd be like we
are this guy anywhere we're going to cut
off his Communications he's danger nope
they're like you're free to go sir have
a nice day because it's political they
want to campaign off his mug shot as
much as Trump wants to campaign off his
mug shot the danger is if both sides are
using civil Conflict for fundraising and
and generating votes it only ends in one
place you eventually end up with a
politician saying look
they said vote for me and I will put
them in prison Trump trump said it first
and then didn't do it then they said it
and now they're doing it Trump get gets
reelected Revenge he starts doing it
then they're gonna say it's illegitimate
at what point does someone say no and
then there's a clash I gotta tell you
I'm looking at these videos and I'm
having scary Eerie feelings what is the
legitimacy of the squad car in front of
the jail
taking Donald Trump in on these BS fake
charges the police in Georgia
my fear is the actions they have just
taken there's a photo of them like
Trump's walking out in there in front of
them and things like that it makes them
look like they are illegitimate and they
have no Authority
I'm imagining this scenario
a police officer is imagine this there's
a cop standing on the side of the street
a homeless man walks up and says I want
you to arrest that woman he goes you got
a boss and then he goes and does it and
you're watching it happen being like
why are you arresting that woman that's
a random homeless guy
what we have here is that's my analogy I
don't understand
how they can expect to maintain
a view of legitimacy of law enforcement
when one crime is skyrocketing people
are ransacking Nike stores and malls and
and grocery stores and they're not
arresting these people
with the covid lockdowns they punished
regular innocent people and already
conservatives were outraged there's the
videos of the cops stomping on The Thin
Blue Line Flags
now you have more than half the country
slightly more that believe this is
political and illegitimate and they
watch a police officer engage in plainly
political illegitimate Behavior the only
thing now stopping people from
disrespecting the rule of law is a fear
of violence that was a large component
of it but there was often I would say in
this country there was a fear of a a
respect of authority and a fear of being
shunned by the community so it wasn't
just the cops could assert force over
you for many people it was but for a lot
of regular law-abiding citizens it was
it's the wrong thing to do we respect
the police the police don't respect you
the police are letting criminals run
rampant the police arrested that poor
young man in New York who tried to save
people on a train the police arrested
Kyle Rittenhouse they put him in jail
how could anyone watch what they're
doing to a former president and think
the police are acting in a legitimate
way
I when I looked at the live video that
outside outside the jail and you got the
squad car there I'm just like it looks
like clown car to me I just I don't feel
it anymore I do not feel it it feels
like these cops are are derelict it
feels like they are illegitimate and
that worries me because if I'm seeing
this now and I'm not even the biggest
Trump guy I can't imagine what anyone
else is thinking about it no it's
impossible I mean you're you're the
history guy here does this remind you of
anything else
not in this country no
um other countries yeah that's that's
now I'm interested what other countries
yeah like um you've got Brazil you know
most recently with Lula and yeah I mean
Glenn Greenwald talks about it and then
um from my understand Korea has been
doing it it's common and you know
Eastern Bloc countries things like that
but what about historically
you know when countries Fall Into
Revolution regime change war Civil War
I mean a lot of people have said there
are similarities between this and the
Spanish Civil War I think
that's I've heard that the most
that this that what's going on here
tracks alongside the Spanish Civil War
more than anything else
I haven't followed it so I'll take your
word for it I don't know I don't know
anything about it it just seems bizarre
that this would be the route that you
know we take now I mean I was reading
CNN today and they were saying this is
unprecedented first first time in
history something like this has happened
you want to say you think that's a good
thing like do you think this is the
direction you want to take the country
if you're the party that's in power is
this the precedent you want to set I
mean theoretically if the scales it back
Trump's elected or novel how many times
have you heard the word that's novel
charges we've never seen a virus no save
charges never um the RICO Act is novel
Jack Smith is novel
which means we're making this up as
we go
where is any Republican to do the
smallest bit
don't get me wrong like federally we got
Jim Jordan saying you know I I hereby
Demand with a strongly worded letter
I want to see what you've got in your
documents and it's live well she
probably crumbled that up and throw it
in the trash blew her nose in it first
where's the subpoena at the state level
where are the indictments you've got uh
let me you were gonna say something oh I
was just gonna ask do any of the like
the strong word letter is obviously
ridiculous but at the same time does he
have to issue it to give her a chance to
turn over the documents before he can
get a subpoena like I don't know what
the I'm not sure because questioning her
could be part of the investigation right
I mean we want to bring you in and talk
to you about what's going on because how
do we determine what we're charging or
what we're actually writing out right
get your ass over here we got a problem
come come on up here it is crazy that
she's not in DC answering questions
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time